the trump national golf club in
bedminster new jersey is hosting the
live golf series bankrolled by the
sovereign wealth fund of saudi arabia
the tournament has sparked outrage among
those who lost family members in the 9
11 attacks
we're standing here in the backyard of
where 750 people were turned to dust
brett eagleson's father was killed that
day
if it were not for the kingdom support
those hijackers would have had a zero
percent chance of success and we that's
our goal is to educate the world on that
fact
family members have accused donald trump
and the pro-golfers who are
participating of taking blood money my
two brothers were murdered on 9 11. i
live every single launching an ad to
remind them that 15 of the 9 11
hijackers were saudi citizens
they say recently declassified documents
show the hijackers had help from the
saudi government something the kingdom
has denied
trump has expressed sympathy for the
families but no regrets about hosting
the event
well i've known these people for a long
time in saudi arabia and they've been
friends of mine for a long time
they've invested in many american
companies they own big percentages of
many many american companies and frankly
what they're doing for golf is so great
what they're doing for the players is so
great the salaries are going to go way
up
the former president has promoted the
live series with its huge payouts for
players as an alternative to the pga of
america which yanked its 2022
championship from his bedminster course
after the january 6 capital attack
terry strata who lost her husband tom in
the world trade center says she's
equally disturbed by president joe
biden's recent interaction with crown
prince mohammed bin salman it was
disgraceful it was painful to watch such
a you know such a nonchalant way of
meeting him when we were trying to get
our point across you need to have a
really serious conversation with him
about september 11th
and he blew it 9 11 families aren't the
only ones outraged by the saudi-backed
golf tournament the national press club
pointing to the killing of journalist
jamal khashoggi has called the event a
revolting attempt to whitewash the
kingdom's image
kristen salumi al jazeera bedminster new
jersey